take a moment to appreciate the Batman
and the penguin are on-screen together
again involving a circus put get how
many movies as Tim Burton done that
involves a circus three that I can think
of off the top of my head he claims to
hate circuses dude not so secretly loves
them come on
[Music]
Dumbo so Dumbo is the newest movie in
the sloop Disney live-action adaptations
of pre-existing Disney properties and of
course Dumbo is about the elephant with
the big ears who could fly Dumbo is a
funny thing Dumbo the movies like an
hour and 10 minutes long so they fill it
up with well there's a lot more plot
here his plot involves Colin Farrell or
return soldier from the war his kids
they work in a circus Danny DeVito runs
the circus and there's Michael Keaton's
character who runs a bigger circus it
pretty much operates like any
multi-channel network here on YouTube
they're bigger they want to make money
they don't care about the talent they
have or the fans they just want to be
seen as legit so they bring people in
under their umbrella who are more
talented than them the entities they can
be like hey look how cool we are
any MCN don't join them they're our
waste of time so a lot more happens in
this version of Dumbo and I'm gonna talk
about what I liked in Dumbo what that is
well first of all Dumbo Dumbo is damn
adorable I love Dumbo anything involving
Dumbo is just I don't know melted my
heart I'm both sweet Dumbo's cute you're
pulling for Dumbo I mean the live-action
cast for the most part was fine but
really the CGI baby elephant that's what
brought it I know sweet and cute baby
elephant doesn't make for a good
character or good movie what I'm saying
is that the pretty good foot to start
out on so right out the gate you're like
I like Dumbo so what else he got by the
end of the movie Dumbo was the motion of
the movie really anything that broke my
heart
anytime I was pulling for a character it
wasn't the kids it wasn't the adults
it was the CGI baby elephant when I say
fine I mean fine like most people in
this movie are fine Michael Keaton is
actually my least favorite character
by contrast Danny DeVito I thought was
really good for what his character was
he's an eccentric owner of a traveling
circus he plays it as Danny DeVito would
well Michael Keaton's character is a
super corporate guy I feel like Michael
Keaton was doing an impersonation of
Johnny Depp doing a role in a Tim Burton
film think when watching it I was like
that's clearly supposed to be Johnny
Depp right come on let's not lie here
when the movie wants to hit the emotion
home it does like when Dumbo flies
you're like you're on spire do you feel
like a member of the audience like
huh-uh
the score starts swelling up and has
that payoff when he flies and that's
what it is when this movie remembers
it's supposed to give you that inspiring
feeling it does doesn't change the fact
that the movie does go the transformers
issue out let me explain here for a
second I mean the original animation of
transformers transformers was about
transformers the humans were the side
characters they didn't need to be in it
but they were in it to anchor the show
to our world for the
when the movie came out the movie was
about the human characters Dumbo kind of
does that it's Disney animals talking
Disney animals even talkin live-action
adaptations of Disney movies by Disney
but in Dumbo animals don't talk the
mouse side character friend he has a
cameo he's in a cage but he's not part
of the movie and it really revolves
around the kids in the human but it
doesn't change the fact that for the
human characters I was kind of invested
in him that is invested as maybe the
movie wanted me to be that's the more
invested than I thought I was gonna be
fun even if I hadn't really seen Dumbo
since I was like four and the babysitter
would put it on the laserdisc and show
me just alright that'll shut him up and
she'd just show me Dumbo all the other
kids were at school I was too young to
go to school so the Dumbo animation is
not fresh in my mind but as I was
watching this movie there were these
callbacks that was just loud I was like
oh my gosh yeah I remember that kind of
oh my gosh I remember that's like some
weird subconscious awakening really
things that I clearly don't remember I
don't think it I don't remember them
because I was too young I just don't
remember them because they weren't in
the animation like I don't remember some
super circus that was in direct
competition of the little circus and the
super circus looked like some Tim Burton
steampunk dystopia something like that
so the movie's not in accurate and some
of its imagery it does take liberties
for the plot in the end Dumbo there's
like a banana split I didn't like all
the toppings on it even the things that
I usually like I don't like as the
toppings in here talking about that
pineapple topping I like pineapple what
is that what is it what I'm trying to
say is like a banana split it's messy
and sweet and I did in the end enjoy
myself and I will say Dumbo is a pretty
good time to alcohol required I will say
there are some things in here might be
too dark for some little kids as Tim
Burton would do involving some circus
stuff is like there's some things that
are like here's some death and dark
imagery you're like dude Burton come on
for kids right no I do kind of want to
see Tim Burton do a Pinocchio movie so I
see what he does with Pleasure Island I
mean oh my god all right so Dumbo have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]